la campaña militar a gran escala de
Israel contra el campo de refugiados de
llenín afronta su segundo día que podría
ser decisivo pues el ejército israelí
dice que hoy Busca debilitar otros 10
sitios más de las milicias palestinas
usaba supuestamente para guardar armas y
fabricar explosivos y que se sumarían a
esos otros centros de operaciones que ya
ha destruido como lo explicábamos ayer
Israel está defendiendo esta operación
en yin titulada casa y jardín como un
golpe al campamento que lo considera un
refugio del terrorismo sin control de la
autoridad nacional Palestina de ahí que
haya interrogado a más de 120 palestinos
y estime que en el lugar habría unos 300
milicianos armados de distintas
facciones palestinas no obstante Y
aunque en la noche no ha habido casi
enfrentamientos la situación para los
civiles del campamento Es realmente
grave en un espacio de menos de medio
kilómetro cuadrado para garantizar su
seguridad unas 3.000 personas unas 500
familias fueron evacuadas anoche por la
luna roja Palestina un desplazamiento
que fue difícil por los destrozos en el
campo y que según medios palestinos se
propició porque Israel les lanzó un
ultimátum de desalojo algo que Israel ha
negado pese a las imágenes de personas
saliendo con las manos en alto y
soldados comprobando el interior de las
casas además como ha denunciado la
agencia humanitaria de la ONU los
bombardeos israelíes y las aplanadoras
israelíes han dañado casas carreteras y
las redes de agua y electricidad está
faltando agua y alimento mientras el
hospital principal de llenín está
completamente desbordado Incluso el área
ha sufrido el lanzamiento de gases
lacrimógenos por parte de Israel ante
este panorama la OMS la Organización
Mundial de la Salud le ha insistido a
Israel que permita el paso de
socorristas dentro del campo y Es que
concluya hoy o no esta no será la última
gran operación israelí como advertido el
jefe militar israelí en cisjordania
ocupada